invité ce soir c'est le sénateur
dominique théophile bonsoir bonsoir donc
chargé de mission sergas avec un
objectif chercher bien sûr des solutions
pour ramasser des sargasses est
dévalorisé ou est-ce que vous en êtes
aujourd'hui bien la mission qui m'a été
confiée démarre aujourd'hui c'est depuis
hier à la martinique puisque nous devons
nous rendre à sainte lucie et comme la
préfecture de martinique c'est la
préfecture de zone sur ces questions là
mais nous avons voulu entamer la mission
ici en martinique rencontrer les acteurs
rencontrés tous les élus et voir en
quelque sorte remplir ma mission qui
était en analyser les stratégies de
lutte contre le phénomène et chercher
des solutions avec avec au bout de la
mission un rapport de plus finalement
examiné des techniques de ramassage de
valorisation et de stockage et puis
analyser aussi fait l'état des lieux de
la coopération internationale puisque
c'est une mission à l'international
caraïbes et des pays proches de la
guyane on a vu que le ministre veut
nicolas hulot et la ministre annemie
jardin chez nous au mois deux mois de
juin dernier il avait annoncé un plan de
10 millions d'euros pour lutter contre
les s'agace un plan je crois qu'ils
étaient répartis sur deux ans où est ce
qu'on a mais aujourd'hui mais ça suit
son cours le dispositif est et est en
marche pour organiser suite à l'annoncé
financier à votre du gouvernement et
n'oublions pas que l'arrivée mon adjoint
de nicolas hulot est donné que j'ai
regardé sur la question c'est suite à
vraiment une alerte des populations mais
aussi son agent d allah a baby sûr
puisque ce sont des préfectures qui gf1
caméras des affronts ça va servir à
aider dans une preuve dans un premier
temps les collectivités à s'organiser
pour l'urgence puisque il y a à la fois
de chantier l'urgence et les
préconisations pour arriver à new delhi
nationale par les 2,3 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour faire face donc à
l'échouage et acheter des machines
c'est donc une annonce également des
ministres de quelle machine ça y est il
ou est-ce qu'on ment mais aujourd'hui on
est alors alors bien évidemment il va
falloir s'équiper puisque aujourd'hui
nous sommes balbutiant de ce phénomène
là il n'y a pas
de deux machines déjà adapté totalement
à cela il ya des expertises qui sont
faites l ademe et nautiques dead à la
décision au choix
les chantiers sont ouverts des
collectivités s'engagent à la fois sûr
lorsque en guadeloupe puis à la
collectivité régionale et d'autres qui
se sont engagés sur l'équipement après
la martinique aussi mais après le gros
travail qui doit faire c'est
d'harmoniser tout cela il a fait bien
sûr qu'ils subissent ceux ci donc le
phénomène des sargasses on pense
naturellement aux marins pêcheurs qu'en
est-il de l'indemnisation justement des
marins pêcheurs et des entrepreneurs qui
sont dans l'activité est hypothéquée par
des salaires bien sûr le volet de la
mission n'est pas sur les indignations
bien évidemment un dispositif qui existe
déjà et puis qui sera renforcé avec la
mort soir je suppose mais c'est comme ça
d'habitude cela se passe mais encore
beaucoup plus pointu parce qu'il s'agit
de perte de chiffre d'affaires de marge
et puis parfois sur des territoires
c'est pratiquement l'arrêt d'une
économie en exemple de la guadeloupe
l'île de marie galante et en
l'occurrence la commune de capesterre de
marie-galante ac c'est pratiquement
toute activité économique et donc il va
falloir prendre en compte les cci et la
préfecture il s'engage sur ce coup là
mais dès votre mission ne ferait pas
seulement donc à la martinique et la
guadeloupe vous n'aurez les regards des
amendes maintenant la caraïbe
qu'est ce que vous avez vu chez nos
voisins qu'ils peuvent être intéressants
mais c'est ce que je vais voir chez nos
voisins ne vous fasse de cette icône oui
mais ça ce sont des figures et des
annonces des suppositions gérer on ira
toucher du doigt est vraiment faire du
mönch marque dessus qui se fait
réellement et puis on a à prendre
puisque le phénomène sargasses qui était
un phénomène dans nos têtes épisodique
comme ça 2011 à l'échelle du phénomène
c'est tout près aujourd'hui on ce qu'on
sait c'est que ce sera récurrent et
qu'il va falloir mettre un dispositif
qui puisse répondre à l'ampleur de la
situation donc agir sur le phénomène
dans son territoire ou dans des
territoires ne sera pas suffisant je
pense que c'est à l'échelle
internationale que cela peut se régler
et c'est le but de la mission une
dernière 400 qui vous concernent en
avril dernier je me trompe vous aviez
évoqué
une proposition de loi pour transférer
la compétence du ramassage des sargasses
à l'état en mer avant leur échouage ce
projet de loi donc exempterait les
collectivités locales et de leurs
obligations techniques et financières -
est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui
c'est une proposition de loi comme toute
proposition de loi qui doit atteindre
soit une niche parlementaire ou bien
vouloir de la commission à laquelle elle
a été déposée parce que je disais est ce
que j'ai dit dans la proposition de loi
qu'il faut à la fois se voulait que
venait d'indiquer mais privilégie le
ramassage en mer ce qui aujourd'hui est
d'une évidence aussi puisque toutes les
machines qui sont regardés
c'est à l'approché dans le lamer quoi
donc que faut pas attendre l'échouage
parce que ça pose des difficultés
sanitaires et que l'idéal jo c'est qu'on
ait dit oui une modélisation une
configuration qui puisse répondre à ce
phénomène qui troquerait nos territoires
et les plus nominés de nos pays merci
sénateur dominique théophile jamais de
chargés de mission car gaza